Nothing is more expensive than bad information.
Know the source.
One Radio Network dot com.
Well welcome to hour two or part two or whatever you want to call it of our little show here
we do virtually every morning except for maybe Thursdays or so on One Radio Network dot com.
My name is Patrick Timpone and on the third Monday of the month, second part of the show,
we have Dr. Ray Peat on PhD and you'll meet him in just a second.
Let me just give a quick little plug what's going to happen tomorrow.
Christine Northrup is going to be on the show.
She's really an interesting lady.
I think you're going to enjoy her.
Paul Rider and Brandon Smith on Wednesday and they're both into the geopolitical financial
world and I think you're going to find both of them well worth listening to.
So that's coming up Wednesday.
Probably somebody else during this week too.
Dr. Jennifer Daniels next week.
Richard Mayberry next week.
A lot of cool things coming up.
We're going to have a Fourth of July special with Jack Graham and he's going to tell you
some things about the Declaration of Independence that you said, "Whoa!" or the revolution.
That's not possible.
So that's all coming up.
So join us now and please just use the email this morning for some reason.
For some reason we just can't get the 800 number to be working this morning.
So we'll work on that and have it for you tomorrow.
Ray Peat, a PhD at University of Oregon.
He specialized in physiology.
He started his work on hormones way back 50 years ago.
I was getting out of the military or in the military and Ray Peat was working on hormones
in 1968.
He wrote his dissertation with outlining the ideas on progesterone and hormones.
So he's been at it for a very long time.
As I said, on the third Monday of every month, Dr. Ray Peat is with us and he's right here.
Good morning, sir.
How are you?
Good morning.
I'm very well.
Well, you sound very well.
How do you spend most of your days these days?
Reading.
A little painting.
I'm sorry, the last?
Mostly just reading but occasionally painting some.
Painting too, huh?
And what kind of things do you read?
Most recently I was reading about a trial in Spain.
The murder of the six Jesuits and their housekeeper and her daughter after 31 years.
They're finally bringing the vice-ministrate of defense to trial in Spain for murdering
their priest.
So you just go for things that are just interesting to you, not necessarily always in the health
realm.
No, I try to keep up a little bit on the news.
So you sent me your last newsletter.
Thanks for that.
And you're saying that the argument of this, and I'm just going to read the first line
as I read it with Dr. Massey, is a failure of energy metabolism limits the ability of
cells to return from an excited active state to a stable resting state.
An unresolved excitation causes cells to emit signals indicating the need for repair, inflammatory
signals.
Pre-existing inflammation is associated with high altitude sickness and the ability to
get sick from the coronavirus as well as chronic diseases.
This implies that treatment for a so-called coronavirus infection should be to reduce
cellular excitation and inflammation and normalize energy production.
It also implies that these treatments will have favorable effects on cell aging.
So Dr. Massey was talking earlier, and I wonder if this ties in.
So is it possible that the lungs and the cells were doing something in response to the body's
fear or angst or anything?
Yeah, the emotions, a person, for example, a sick person or an extremely old and frail
person will often lose control of their emotions and have exaggerated intensity of emotions.
That's because the emotional system is stabilized in a young person so that they can experience
something very upsetting.
And within hours or at most maybe a few days, they'll be all the way back to normal.
But if a person's health is a little borderline, a fairly moderate emotional shock can linger
for weeks and weeks like post-traumatic stress disorder.
A very tough person can go through the same experience without the brain consequences.
So I see.
So as the organism is stronger, it's easier to deal with the emotions that come up and
then let them go and move on.
I see.
So you're saying that this is, but this is about the lungs as well.
What's the connection there with the lungs?
The brain is just an extreme example of what's going on in every kind of cell.
The idea of excitation and recovery, you see it in the nerve as an electrical and chemical
change in which you disturb the nerve and it goes into an extreme metabolically intense
process.
And then as it builds up its ATP again, it goes back to the resting state and is ready
for another stimulus.
Exactly that same thing happens in secretory cells, for example.
You irritate it and it'll give a burst of secretion.
And then if there's energy and oxygen, sugar being supplied, it'll quickly recover its
ability to secrete again.
And the lung surface cells, for example, some of them are secreting mucus, others secrete
various smaller molecules, but everything is metabolically active and irritation intensifies
that activity and energy helps it return to its ready to work resting state.
So is it possible that folks who maybe were sheltered in place and going through stress
and being kind of confined, that when they are "allowed" to get back out, that the
body could be healing, which could demonstrate symptoms that they're actually sick?
Oh, for sure.
Wow.
Especially if they've lost their job or their business while being shut down, it's the bigger
consequences.
For some people, it's believing what Fauci and Gates are telling them and believing that
there's really a special pandemic going on this year or something radically different
from last year.
Is it your research and opinion then that the body then does show symptoms when it's
actually getting healing rather than being sick with inflammation and such?
If you're really strong and healthy, you can heal a slight wound without inflammation,
like a healthy fetus.
For example, a surgeon takes a sample of tissue and if the mother is healthy, the wound will
heal without inflammation and without leaving a scar.
And a very healthy young person will take a wound that will close right up without making
a big sore, inflamed area.
It just sort of relaxes back into place and starts closing up the wound.
So it's the idea then, the stronger and stronger we are, the more we can do without being sore,
like exercising and stuff like that.
If we haven't for a while, the body's going to react more severely.
Yeah.
For example, an old person who suddenly decides to do weightlifting or whatever will probably
have lingering symptoms for three or four days where a young person would be sore overnight
maybe but be entirely back in a day or so.
Dr. Ray Peet is with us and you can get that newsletter.
And it's RayPeetNewsletter, right?
At gmail.com?
At gmail.com.
Yeah, yeah.
And Patrick Timpona here with you.
And as I said, the 800 numbers are off.
So just do the email.
Patrick@OneRadioNetwork.com.
As you know, Dr. Peet, more and more states are now reporting more cases.
And they use that term, of course, cases.
And I guess they're tying it into the idea that if you are tested and you're positive
then you are a case, right?
So they're reporting more cases.
And the governor of Florida came out and said, "Well, yes, we're reporting more cases."
And so I think that's a good thing.
And I think that's a good thing.
Can you explain to us this test that they're doing?
So it was ridiculous.
People on the staff and professors were shocked when they learned that the numbers didn't
mean anything because they were mixing two totally different types of tests.
One showed the presence of the virus.
The other showed immunity to the virus.
So the government itself has been probably deliberately covering up, blurring, essentially
destroying meaningful information.
So the test today that is being given, and they have this swab thing, even drive-thrus,
and lots of people are doing it.
Is it possible that they can actually show a virus that is COVID-19, that is separate
from other kind of stuff in the body?
Can they really, can they do that?
To a certain extent, it can show.
Sometimes it can be right, but it's often false positive.
Junk, junk will sometimes cause the reaction.
So junk or antibodies and things like that actually shows up as an actual virus?
Well, other pieces of RNA can get amplified.
The presence of a certain stretch of RNA is also amplifying and measuring with the
polymerase chain reaction test.
If they find the presence of the virus, the fact that somewhere between 35 and 80% of
people can have the virus present and no symptoms at all.
So what does it mean if they find the virus present?
It can be just a few stray viruses that might be stuck somewhere or not.
But since as many as 80% of the people don't have any symptoms when they have the virus,
the presence of a positive test usually is meaningless.
It means that they're simply not reacting to a virus, so it isn't a pathogen.
So if there's a corona COVID, what's the correct term?
Is it COVID-19?
That's the actual virus that they claim?
Yeah.
Okay.
So if this test can show a COVID-19 in the PCR tests they're giving in some cases, then
that means that that exists.
It must exist then, right?
Somewhere.
Yeah.
They argue that it is the number 19 rather than last year's.
There are so many of them and they're changing so often that you don't really know for sure
what the test was standardized on.
I see.
So what you're saying, I hear you say it could show up some kind of a corona-type viruses
and there's a lot of them, but we don't know that much about it, if it's very special,
where it came from, is it communicable?
Yeah, the people who make, they get a sample that they declare to be the real thing.
And then you really have to test the test to see whether what it's finding is meaningful.
But they just haven't done any big testing.
The FDA rushed them into use without testing the tests.
So you can show that over and over, it will truly reflect the standard you have in the
lab.
Yes, it's amplifying that and has a very high reliability for that known virus.
But when you go out and test it on people without standardizing the test, you don't
know how sensitive it is to discriminating against junk RNA.
I see.
And how long would it take, in your opinion, to do that correctly?
Several months, probably thousands of people would have to be tested, doing multiple tests
when you get a positive, then examining them more carefully to see what the positive consists
of.
For example, you should have to test, examine, looking for other coronaviruses.
If you find other coronavirus positives in the person who tested positive for COVID-19,
then that weakens the meaning of your test.
If you aren't testing for other related things, how do you know for sure what you have found?
So all of these different flu and cold viruses, as I understand, they are a corona genre type
virus?
There's a lot of them?
Yeah, the coronavirus has been known to cause colds for decades.
So there's no evidence then that whatever this COVID-19 is that they've called is any
different or stronger or unique?
Is there any evidence?
Very, very little evidence.
The best evidence, the Stanford professors about three months ago were getting different
ways of looking at existing evidence and studies on people in California and looking at the
cruise ship that was infected.
Both of those approaches showed that it was very similar to the standard flu pathogenicity
and possibly less, but in vicinity of a fraction of 1% mortality of those infected, which is
in the range of the annual flu viruses.
Dr. Rapita, is it possible that whatever these PCR tests are seeing that they're claiming
is a unique coronavirus could be being produced by the body, an endosome or an exosome has
been argued?
Our DNA is full of stuff that looks like RNA viruses.
Some people say that it's half of our DNA, which is about twice as much DNA as we need
for our genes that construct all of us.
So there is this mysterious, dark, non-genetic DNA, which gives signs of being related to
the RNA viruses.
So it's very possible that stored in this immense amount of DNA that there are already
some overlapping bits of RNA.
When you're under stress, we put out exosomes and they're in the same size range and structural
composition of this type of virus.
Very similar under the microscope, little round particles that are synthesized in a
certain part of the cell and stream out of the cell being secreted in the blood.
But under stress, these are repair particles.
Injured cells will send signals, for example, to the bone marrow and the bone marrow will
manufacture exosome material containing RNA and DNA and proteins that help to repair the
injured cells in other parts of the body.
The stem cell system is largely regulated through these exosomes and internal communication
system.
And so the stress that turns those on happens to be the stress that the viruses use to activate
their own synthesis and secretion.
So is it possible then that stress or poisons or other insults on the body could be producing
an exosome that looks just like a virus and is being identified as a virus?
Yeah, the important thing is that if the official government approved researchers won't even
look at this gigantic part of our DNA system, they're going to question whether we already
have some very similar coronavirus type RNA in our reservoir of genetic information, which
will come out under stress.
If you don't look at it, you'll never find it.
So is it possible that people under stress, having to wear a mask, having to stay home,
losing their job, worried about their finances and their family could be creating these exosomes
that could be shown up then as a virus?
Any stress can increase your exosome manufacture.
But it's a fairly small industry to study the exosome system.
And the basic problem is that it was denied as contrary to the basic dogma of genetics
and molecular biology.
It's the epigenetic system.
RNA viruses were said to be impossible because of the dogma that says information goes only
from DNA to RNA to protein.
And so for a virus to contain only RNA, but to get into our DNA went in the wrong direction.
So the whole thing required about, well, 50 years ago it started, but the scientific community
gradually adapted to accept that RNA viruses are a real thing.
But seeing the whole genome, the whole DNA content of cells, seeing that as active and
functional, that's the hard part.
They just prefer not to get involved in that, especially as it relates to immunity because
it opens up the area of doubt about a million fold.
Doubt for the germ theory, vaccines, and pharmaceuticals?
Yeah, basically the antibody vaccine theory would totally melt away into nothing if people
started looking at the actual immune system.
Wow.
So, Dr. Rapi, then was this what Pasteur was arguing, that there are RNA things out there,
viruses that are separate from us and can attack us?
I mean, that was his premise, right?
Yeah, there are things out there, but the dogma says that they originated separately
and what the evidence looks like is that these circulating viruses, probably since they can't
evolve, they can't exist except in a higher organism, you can't evolve a lower thing like
a virus if its existence depends on a mammal, for example.
You can't conceive of it coming into existence de novo, so you have to see it as a product
of a higher organism.
We or other organisms under stress create exosomes, some of these get emitted into the
environment and they spread information between organisms the way bacteria, if one bacterium
is exposed to an antibiotic, it can produce a little particle, a bacteria equivalent of
an exosome, having the genes which make it able to resist the antibiotic and it will
approach another bacterium of a different strain even or even a different species.
There's evidence that this particle can be transmitted across a fair genetic difference.
So one bacterium sends out a little tube connecting it to another bacterium that wasn't exposed
and passes this particle of genetic information and the other bacterium can then integrate
it and reproduce and all of its descendants will be immune to antibiotic.
So if bacteria can do it, it's only the genetic dogma of one-way information that makes people
resistant to looking at the transmission of these particles between organisms.
So if you're around stress organisms, this approach would say you're at risk of catching
their stress.
So let's see, so say a husband is stressed and creates exosomes and starts the process
of healing I suspect, then the wife could experience the same thing because?
She's going to teach her body, help her body to learn how to become immune from this thing.
Yeah.
The basic principle would probably be like the bacteria adapted and passed its adaptation
onto its neighbors and the mechanism as far as it exists in plants and animals would be
to pass these useful repair units onto other members of the family.
Yes.
So that could be possible then just a kind of a God, whatever you want to call it, evolutionary
process to make the species stronger.
Species helping everybody to get stronger essentially is what I hear you saying.
Yeah.
There have been people making good arguments for this among plants in particular going
back 50, 60 years.
So do we always have to feel symptoms, flu-like headache or whatever, when we take on one
of these little repair guys to get stronger?
Do we have to feel bad?
No, not at all.
The fact that they're finding positive RNA evidence of the virus in people who don't
have any symptoms at all, maybe 80% of the people don't feel anything from it.
So it's being passed on and probably integrated on creating better immunity in 80% of the
people.
But if you have a sick, stressed, unhappy, malnourished population, they are going to
have trouble adapting.
Okay, so there will be some people that will die, or could die, right?
Because they're just sick or compromised in preconditions and the rest of it.
Yeah, that would be the 1/10 to 1/4 of 1% infected.
Yeah, what's happening.
It's just not happening.
Yeah.
Because of age and preconditions.
That's at some level.
Yeah.
In Spain, or Italy, the mortality of men is 70%, almost three times greater mortality,
but it's especially old men.
And young women, the only young women that were dying were very, very sick individuals,
menstruating women of ordinary health were extremely resistant to the infection.
Is there any evidence that the mortality rate of this particular virus or this particular
flu season is any more severe than others?
Other years?
Not really.
These figures suggest that it's a fairly typical year for mortality.
A few people have been watching a very odd thing in the CDC figures.
Starting last fall, we were noticing a very unhistorical decline in the total national
mortality.
A dip.
People just weren't dying of anything as often as they should.
Old age or accidents or whatever normally kill people.
There was a great drop in mortality week after week, and 15% in many weeks through the winter.
And suddenly, in the first week of April, the people who had been missing from the national
mortality, suddenly there was this spike in excess mortality.
If you somehow had a block between the reporting of the deaths starting last fall and the recording
of them in the CDC, and then suddenly you broke the barrier to recording these deaths,
that could account for this huge spike in excess mortality because there had been a
buildup of deficient mortality for weeks.
So this whole idea of the so-called second wave, what would you expect, just knowing
what you understand how this works, if people start to come out of their shelter in place,
take off their mask, and don't do the six feet and all that?
Should we expect to see symptomatics being, whatever they mean, more?
And then if people get tested more, the numbers could theoretically "get worse."
Right?
Possible?
Yeah, I think that's what's happening.
They're confusing the result of testing more.
They're saying, "Look, we're catching a lot of infections."
That means it's increasing, but people don't necessarily get sick when they have the virus
in them.
So you shouldn't be looking at anything except who is sick.
Yeah.
And so in your opinion, who is running the show here on a big picture of coming up with
this story?
Is it the WHO and the CDC?
Who's involved in this?
Do you have any idea?
Both of them.
They're tightly integrated with the pharmaceutical industry.
They are now just another agency controlled by not only the pharmaceutical industry, but
if you look at what happened last fall in the Federal Reserve System, they started putting
out that $6 trillion into the economy last fall before anyone was talking about a virus
at all.
And then there was a historically big wave of resignations of CEOs of the biggest corporations
late last fall, long before the stock market crash.
So they had inside news.
I saw a video in which Bill Gates was saying, "We were totally unprepared.
We weren't anticipating this at all.
We need to do better and be anticipating further waves of infection."
He was one of the motivators of a program to model and create a play of how they would
respond to it.
They had leaders of industry and finance and the health systems, pharmaceutical industry,
get together last October and anticipate how they would respond to a pandemic caused by
a coronavirus imported into the United States.
So it was all sketched out that they would have a dramatic new way of responding to a
pandemic.
And a pandemic isn't necessarily a big thing.
It can be an international wave of colds.
It doesn't mean it's going to be anything deadly or very harmful.
Are you speaking of the 2001 thing that they had?
Event 201.
Yeah, Event 201.
That was sponsored by the Gates and those people?
Yeah.
Very interesting.
Dr. Ray Peet is with us, Patrick Timpone on Radionetwork.com.
He's here on the third Monday at around 1030.
I started a few minutes late.
Stay right there, Dr. Peet.
We're going to do a quick break and then we're going to dig into your emails.
Over 7 trillion right now on the Fed's balance sheet.
So that's about, oh, I think 3 trillion or so treasury bonds that have been purchased
by the private Federal Reserve Bank in the last three or four months.
We're going to be speaking more about this with Brandon Smith of AltFinance.com.
Very interesting fellow.
He's going to be on 11 o'clock on Wednesday.
So we'll keep you abreast of this.
And then just so you know, there's about 3 trillion more that have been going out through
the Fed, through the back door without being on their balance sheet, going through hedge
funds like BlackRock and things like that.
So this stuff is all out there if you look for it.
And so we try to keep you updated.
Well, you know, it's a big challenge to living on planet Earth with cell phones, Wi-Fis and
stuff.
We don't recommend you have a Wi-Fi in your home, but we do what we can.
I know your kids and you probably like to sit on the couch and play with your phone
and say you like Wi-Fi, but don't do that.
But if you do do that, something like this will help you.
And this will help you even if you don't have Wi-Fi.
Previously, we talked with Brandon Amelani about his Blue Shield product to protect against
EMFs in your home.
The more connected we are, the more electromagnetic radiation we're going to have.
So years ago, I'd play with Q-Links and just anything I can get my hands on that whether
I felt it working or not, I just wanted some kind of leverage against electromagnetic radiation
and those frequencies and how they affect the cellular biology.
But then when I met Mark and started really getting deep to his technology and really
looking at the microprocessing technology, I've never found any EMF company that would
not only to test on not only human blood and urine analysis, but also on animals, which
totally weeds out the idea of placebo effect.
I mean, the fact that you can plug these devices into a chicken farm, a factory farm for about
15,000 laying hens, and all of a sudden the mortality rate, which is averages from 60
to 150 deaths per month, goes down to zero, I mean, it's pretty profound that a little
device, a little energy device could actually create such a harmony and balance within the
environment to where claustrophobic chickens that are crammed in together actually get
along better and actually feel better.
The biological markers are improved over that one year study.
There's quite a bit of science with this Blue Shield product.
You can see the ad on the front page.
Promo code OneRadio will get you a 10% discount.
This works on the cells in the body.
Very cool technology.
Front page, blueshieldoneradionetwork.com.
You betcha.
Don't forget, we have colostrum on sale right now.
It's a big sale.
I need your Thrival Link colostrum, and you're going to use the promo code.
Pick it up again here quickly.
Mouse, help me out here.
WERimmune, W-E-R immune.
Any Sir Thrival Link on OneRadioNetwork.com.
Just put that in there, you're going to get 20% off on all colostrum products on Sir Thrival.
That's a pretty cool thing.
If you'd like to get into some probiotics, we have a great probiotic line.
Check out Richard Ulrey here.
Dr. Richard Ulrey, authority on minerals, talks about gut bacteria, making the vitamins,
and absorbing the minerals.
How it all works.
We need vitamins from our gut bacteria so we can absorb minerals, and then minerals
provide a resonant frequency.
Those minerals carry these frequencies into the body, and multiple minerals will give
you a frequency that allows all of our proteins to have individual distinct frequencies, giving
that three-dimensional structure.
This is where Wayne's products, Living Stream, and that's the only primary products I carry.
When you do a stool test and it says you don't have any bifalbacteria, well if you don't
have any bifalbacteria, you're not going to absorb certain minerals.
If you don't have any lactobacillus, you're not going to absorb certain minerals.
Here's an idea of a couple of the Living Streams you can take for what we're talking
about here.
The bifido, Living Streams Multi-Blend, and the living minerals.
So you get in the minerals, the bifido, and the lactobacillus.
And these special probiotics and minerals are all in human DNA form, and they are living
alive.
In our store on oneradionetwork.com.
We've added two new products to our offerings that we're very excited about, and one is
the Aquatru Top of the Counter Reverse Osmosis System.
If you're watching on Facebook and YouTube, you'll see that, but you'll see it on the
front page.
And it's a really good one.
We've seen the lab analysis, and man, it cleans it all out, everything.
It's like a distiller on the top, but it's reverse osmosis.
But it's a very nice design where it's on the top of the counter.
We really like that.
And then check it out.
They have payment plans that are just terrific.
You just have, just with reasonable, reasonable credit, you can just get a quick little thing
here where you do 12 monthly payments at zero interest.
Isn't that cool?
And then you can also do three monthly payments.
So these are really interesting.
I know many of you have been wanting to try to find a more affordable reverse osmosis
system, and you just keep the filters changed, and you'll be good to go.
It's called the Aquatru, and it's on the front page of One Radio Network.
Click on there, and you can pay it.
And I think the whole price is $3.29, something like that.
For the whole deal, you can do that straight away, or you can do monthly payments, either
three payments at $99.966, and then, or 12 monthly payments.
So good stuff that we're finding.
And these are nice units.
I think you're going to enjoy them, and it's, you know, it'd be better than buying a lot
of bottled water and stuff like that.
And it's really nice water, and it's very important.
The Aquatru on OneRadioNetwork.com.
Know the source.
One Radio Network.
Dr. Ray Peet, who's been at this health investigative and game for 50 years now.
And you had your PhD 50 years ago, Doc.
Actually, it was in 1972.
Oh, '72, okay.
Yeah.
Well, 40 years ago, yeah.
What did you, when you were back there doing your PhD on the whole hormone thing, what
was your kind of vision of where you, did you have an idea of where you wanted to go
with all of this back there 40 years ago?
Oh, yeah.
In 1970, I sketched out about five ideas that I thought might be acceptable to the establishment
in the next 10 or 20, at most by the end of the century.
And one of those I wrote up, sent to a journal, and it was published, Gilbert Ling was the
editor of that journal, published in 1971.
And I was sure that those ideas, that there was so much movement in that direction, I
thought they would be the standard by the 1990s.
And it's true that the supporting evidence has been very heavy in that direction.
But the power from the pharmaceutical industry to return to the 1950 paradigm of how the
body works is so great that despite all of the movement in physics, chemistry, and cell
physiology, the investment in medical school, advertising, product promotion, and so on,
has been able to blot that out, stigmatize the actual facts.
So the dogma is now riding so far above the evidence that you see the journals reacting
to the COVID problem in a basically insane way.
I scanned through the PubMed what the journals were saying about nitric oxide, for example.
There's overwhelming recommendation in the journals to treat COVID by having the person
breathe nitric oxide or take drugs that will increase its production.
The hypertension has been actually treated by giving them sildenafil, what's the male
erection drug called, to create more nitric oxide as a treatment for lung problems.
But in fact, inflammation anywhere, especially in the lungs, creates more nitric oxide.
Nitric oxide creates inflammation and tissue damage.
And people who are susceptible to lung disease, for example, the people before they go to
a high altitude, the ones who are going to get altitude sickness with COVID-like symptoms
in their lungs, these people are already at sea level exhaling more nitric oxide than
normal and as they ascend, the nitric oxide increases and develops into pulmonary respiratory
problems, edema of the lungs.
So they take some mechanical dogma promoted by drug salesmen saying that this is how the
drug works and that it will kill viruses, for example.
So it's appropriate.
But it means that they're recommending the harmful things.
At the same time, they're denying, like Lancet immediately came out with a journal article
saying do not give a treatment that would be appropriate for high altitude pulmonary
edema.
Don't use Losartan, for example.
And when all of this proves to be absolutely 180 degrees false, they'll just blindly go
on and say, "Well, that never happened.
We always recommended anti-inflammatory things and treating the symptoms and so on."
In simplistic terms, in '71 when you submitted this article to Gilbert Ling, what was the
basic differences, what you were saying about how the body works and what the AMA and the
rest were saying?
For example, that the cell is structured all the way down to the atomic level.
Water is organized in the healthy living state and the disorganization of the cell starting
with the water can be measured.
You can see the precancerous conditions by measuring the water.
And you can see the effect of aging, stress, estrogen excess as changes in the water structure.
In the animal, it'll happen half of a lifespan away from the terminal state.
But you can see it coming if you look at the fine structure of the cell, especially the
water.
So what Pollack and other people are arguing, Dr. Pollack, that the water structure inside
our bodies is important.
Oh, yeah.
It's the idea that the cell energy exists in the form of structure.
Structure.
And there is evidence that 5G and other electromagnetic fields disrupts the structure of the water
in the body.
Yeah.
In 1968, just before I went to start graduate school, I visited a lab in Russia, Yuri Holodov,
who had been studying electromagnetic and magnetic fields effects on cell structure.
And he gave me a great list of studies that had already been done.
And those just generally weren't available and were totally unknown in US science.
And what year is this?
'68.
Wow, '68.
This was pre-cell phones.
He was talking about what kind of electrical forces.
He was using all sorts of direct, steady magnetic fields, but the worst are particular frequencies
that the cell resonates to.
Has there ever been any studies with cell phones or cell phone towers and Wi-Fi's tying
all this in together?
Oh, yeah, lots of studies, but the proportion of them focusing on how it acts on water structure,
it's still very small.
Are most of the studies they've done with the potential ill effects of cell phones or
just simply the heat that comes out of these?
Is that correct?
That was the main line story starting back in 1940s and '50s when sailors were being
melted by getting in front of a radar.
The scientific response was it's all the heat and that has gone on all through the last
century claiming that there is no effect other than heat.
And so if the energy level is too small to heat the cell, then there's nothing else it
can do that ignores the fact all radiation interacts with matter with a sort of an antenna
effect.
An antenna for radio or television is stretching a conductor out through space so it absorbs
long wave energy and allows it to be directed to your detector.
But x-rays and ultraviolet and so on, molecular electronic resonance within a molecule or
inside an atom, it's still the principle of an antenna.
The wavelength relating to the structure that is organized will act on that structure and
excite it, change its chemical properties and so on.
And if you deny that there is any meaningful structure between the molecular size and the
whole cell size, then you are deliberately blinding yourself to all of these antenna
effects that relate to the frequencies that can resonate with all of the size ranges between
a molecule and a cell or an organ.
In studies with monkeys and rats, they found that the wavelength equivalent to the size
of the brain or the capsule around any organ is more toxic than wavelengths.
For example, if you have a wavelength that's an inch long or three inches long, the inch
long will affect glands of that size.
For example, the gonads, the one that's three inches long will affect the brain more than
the gonads.
And the same principle applies to all of the levels downward, especially all of the levels
of organization inside the cell.
So you're saying that if the basic structure is denied by the science, then are you saying
they'll never get to the truth of the effects of EMFs?
Yeah, part of that denial is to say that everything that happens inside the cell is like the reactions
that would happen in a test tube.
It's molecules in solutions, simply.
And it's the membrane that acts like the test tube.
And all of standard biochemistry is committed to this dogma that if you grind up a cell
and put it in a test tube with a watery solution, you can infer anything that happens in the
test tube to what happens in the cell because it's all a matter of randomness in solution.
Even though you grind up the cell and destroy the life of the cell, which is what you were
trying to study.
You're painting the picture, if we are allowing this dogma to control the science behind all
of the EMFs, it doesn't really paint a very favorable picture for consumers to ever have
this technology get fixed or slowed down or stopped.
Yeah, and people just have to start seeing that the science that's used as a marketing
tool to say it's all safe, don't study it anymore, it applies to actually every part
of the medical pharmaceutical industries because they're all denying the meaning of structure
in the cell.
Oh, including the AMA?
Oh yeah.
The structure of the cell, wow.
So how did you get onto this so early on?
What was your awakening moment?
Gradually political, listening to politicians and discovering that they're all lying almost
all the time made me suspicious of, especially when politics and medicine get connected.
I started listening for the lies and saw that not only medicine but basic science, they
don't want any questions asked about their assumptions.
I spoke to a few famous biochemists and asked them if they didn't think that it would be
better to use techniques that studied biochemistry and biophysics inside cells rather than squashing
the cell, putting it in a test tube.
And they just laughed and scoffed and what a ridiculous idea.
Dr. Ray Peet is with his PhD.
We're going to dig back and get some leftovers from last month.
I'm sorry we get behind because it's so fascinating talking with this man.
Here is an email, Dr. Peet.
It was about, they wanted to know about the time off progeste as in a natural cycle when
ingested or rub on the gums.
And he said, which he did answer, but I did want to know if time off is also necessary
if it is used only by rubbing into skin and also if that would be the same for males.
When you're using big doses that you feel systemically, that's where the liver becomes
more and more active at excreting it when you're getting these big doses on the level
of a normal menstrual cycle.
And after two weeks of using it, your liver is throwing it off quickly.
So it would only keep rising if you became pregnant.
And that means that if you are not pregnant and have to keep dosing it, the dose would
have to increase in proportion to the liver's activity.
So to make it more efficient, laying off for a week or two lets your liver reset so that
you're not excreting it so fast.
If you're just using it for a topical effect, like a sprain or a burn or something, your
local effect is not going to be harmed.
Here's an email from Rose.
She said, "I've been on Synthroid for 30 years and because of the current virus, I've
been starting to take my temperature in about 96.5 to 97.5.
What can I do to cause my thyroid to function more normally?"
She wants to get her temperature up.
The conversion especially happens mostly in the liver, but in each tissue that needs energy,
it requires glucose and selenium to do the conversion.
And women, by having a higher estrogen production, automatically have a weaker thyroid function
systemically.
That's why women have about five times the rate of thyroid problems because the estrogen
affects the liver and the thyroid.
And then she wants to know how she could get her thyroid to be just better.
Sometimes selenium or getting more sugar in the diet, like orange juice, more frequently,
sometimes that will get the conversion going.
But sometimes a few doses of progesterone can shift the balance, activating the thyroid
gland and liver, which will then tend to stabilize your blood sugar so that the glucose is available
for doing the conversion of T4 to T3.
I see.
All right.
Interesting.
Mark wants to know, "What do I take for a cold sore and what causes them?"
Oh, it's almost always a herpes virus.
The systemic stress, pituitary activation is behind the nerve.
It's the same thing.
Your energy dips and lets the nerve get excited.
The excitation of the nerve gives the virus a chance to reproduce and travel out to the
skin.
So basically keeping your thyroid hormone up so that your blood sugar is stable and
doesn't let your nerves go into these stress states of prolonged excitation.
And then topically, aspirin, well, systemically aspirin is antiviral as well as anti-inflammatory.
So it can reduce the number of outbreaks as well as minimizing the extent of the damage.
But putting a concentrated solution of aspirin and alcohol, for example, on the outbreak
is a safe way to reduce the growth of this disorder and spreading.
So many people have talked about over the years how this little herpes thing doesn't
really want to ever go away and it keeps popping back up under stress.
Is there something unique with this virus that seems to be, I guess, everywhere?
Isn't it that it wants to hang out and doesn't want to just stay more dormant?
I think it's just the stressfulness of society.
Not very good diet, electromagnetic stress in the background all the time.
And it just seems to be one of the ones that pop out more frequently.
Yeah.
Yeah, for whatever reason.
Here is an email from Eric.
He's in Finland.
Good for Finland.
"I have heard that as much as 10,000 I use of vitamin E during a pandemic and otherwise
a daily basis."
So what does Dr. Pete think about this?
Oh, 5,000 every day, but 10,000 during a pandemic of vitamin E.
Of vitamin D. I'm sorry, vitamin D.
Yeah, it overlaps with progesterone in its cell protective stabilizing actions.
And it's been recognized as improving immunity against viruses, but it's working on the same
energy stabilizing system.
It's being considered one of the neuro steroids along with progesterone for brain protective
effect.
Just a reminder on One Radio Network and all of our guests, we don't give any kind of medical
advice.
We're not qualified.
We just give ideas about research and do as thy will and take responsibility for anything
that you do in your life.
And we'd like to remind you that.
Dr. Pete, this is from Chris in Canada.
What could possibly cause sudden drop in blood pressure to something like 79 over 59, making
the person's arms feel numb and progressing to the rest of the body just for a minute
or two, and then the blood pressure could return to normal?
What could possibly be causing that?
Negative things are sometimes behind a surge of toxins from the intestine, for example.
I don't think any particular hormones have been identified for those sudden sharp drops.
I think in the background, low thyroid people are more likely to experience those, similar
to a person who's been squatting for an hour or so, standing up will more likely experience
a blacking out.
The blood pressure doesn't respond as quickly if you have a background of low thyroid activity.
So the getting dizzy when one is down, that was said to be adrenal, but you're suggesting
that's a low thyroid.
Yeah, the adrenals don't respond as quickly when your thyroid is low.
Here's another listener, this one in Europe and Germany from Nuri.
What's the physiological dosage, writes Nuri, of the T4 thyroid hormone?
I take 175, but I still have hypothyroid symptoms and tend to have hyperadrenal function, which
I block with propranolol.
T4 isn't the thyroid hormone, it's a precursor to the active hormone.
It's the same as with women, several times more frequently than men, but it can happen
in men too, the conversion of many things such as a selenium deficiency can make the
liver and other tissues reluctant to convert the T4 to the active hormone.
Prolonged stress hormones will tend to make it go the wrong direction towards reverse
T3 rather than active T3.
Using a better diet, the simplest thing is to use a combination such as natural.
The traditional armor thyroid was what thyroid treatment was based on for the first 50 or
60 years, and then the drug companies got involved testing their T4 product on young
male medical students, healthy male young individuals, and they said it worked just
like the thyroid hormone, just like the natural thing.
But it's exactly slightly older women who they should have tested it on because you
would have found that in women in their 30s and 40s, for example, just about as often
as it improves things, it makes things worse to take only thyroxine.
I see.
So what if there are people that offer just, it's not desiccated, I guess it's just
beef thyroid from grass-fed cows, and that's what it is, somehow they dry it.
I mean, would you have to be careful taking that?
The government required meat packers to discard the thyroid gland starting in the early 1940s.
Before that, it had been included in sausages, and people living on farms would include the
thyroid in soups, sausages, their regular diet would include maybe half a grain equivalent,
30 milligrams of gland if they were eating chicken or fish or beef sausage regularly.
So just to dry it up, thyroid, these are from, I think, New Zealand.
Would that have all the good stuff that people wanted, they could try this instead of the
other pharmaceutical stuff?
Yeah, the thing is that Armour used to have a standardized way of extracting the fat and
dehydrating it and testing the potency on mice, every bat.
So every Armour thyroid pill was highly standardized with biological testing, and now none of that
is done.
The preparation is very different, and so you can hardly tell what to expect when you
take a natural thyroid product.
I see.
So early on, Armour, you were saying, were just doing similar to what you could actually
get online without a prescription, just a beef?
Yeah, some of them that are deep added and dehydrated and pure stuff will be three times
as strong as the old Armour.
Very, very potent.
And others prepared in a different way will be so weak you hardly feel the effect if you
take 150 milligrams of it.
Very interesting.
This is from Thomas, he's in Sweden.
Boy, we have a European contingency.
Well, these are from last month.
I'm still working on last month's emails.
God.
Let's see.
It was quite a nightly problem with leg cramps, and I was trying things like magnesium, potassium
supplements, and it would get really bad if I had indulged in something sweet or salty
in the evening.
Finally, I understood the best cure for this was almost instantaneous was to limp over
to the kitchen and drink a big glass of water.
Now, I just wonder what could be the root cause of this if the hydration could have
fixed the problem?
Possibly dehydration.
Yeah, just dehydrate.
Yeah, the pH of the blood changes if you're suddenly dehydrated.
But milk is a very good bedtime snack because it lowers several of the stress.
Almost all of the stress hormones are lowered by the content of milk.
So the idea that's where it comes from, a warm glass of milk before bed, kind of works.
Dr. Pete, somebody wants to know about your soap.
Is there any natural soaps that are without Prufus?
Do we get Prufus by using soaps with Prufus?
By using what?
By using soap with polyunsaturated fatty acids.
Coconut and olive oils are the traditional best for soaps.
The polyunsaturated fats tend to make the soap go rancid quickly.
So that's why they've historically preferred coconut oil and olive oil.
Do you think extra virgin or I think you had a favorite kind of coconut oil is a good thing
for many people, most, you use your words, to consume regularly, like a big glob of it?
Is it good for us?
If it's well refined, some people are very allergic to coconut, so it's good to be cautious.
Even some refining doesn't get the, if it has a fragrant coconut odor, then you have
to watch out for the allergens.
But allergic reactions, you're only a cautionary tale for coconut oil?
Yeah, otherwise it's very safe and helps to oppose the toxic effects of polyunsaturated
fats.
Oh, it's a counter to Prufus.
Yeah.
Oh, that's great.
But you like to refine because of the allergic, the allergy potential.
Yeah.
Right.
Some people will have a very strong asthma attack or hemorrhoids or other symptoms from
it.
Here's an email from Mary.
Can Dr. P talk about the physiologic role of norepinephrine and norel adrenaline?
Norelpinephrine and norel adrenaline.
Yes, the norepinephrine, was that the first one?
Yes, norel, epinephrine, and then norel adrenaline.
They're the same thing.
Same thing, okay.
The nore is the type that nerves, other than the adrenal glands, form.
But their effect is very similar.
Here's a good one.
50-year-old woman, slightly overweight, menopausal.
I drink milk, OJ, collagen, and honey before bed.
I seem to wake up every day at 3 a.m. wide awake.
Difficult to fall back to sleep.
Any thoughts?
It's okay to just wake up and have a snack, a glass of milk or orange juice.
As the liver gets inefficient from such things as PUFA exposure, estrogen exposure, hypothyroid
or other nutritional deficiencies, it becomes less able to store glycogen enough for the
whole night.
Anna is also in Finland.
She says, "Can you give some advice on how to get rid of varicose veins?
Is natural progesterone lotion useful?"
It can help, but getting your estrogen under control, the reason they so commonly develop
during pregnancy is not only the pressure on the veins and the pelvis, but the estrogen
stops the smooth muscle, reduces the smooth muscle tone, and progesterone activates a
smooth muscle contraction.
So getting the ratio in your body systemically in favor of progesterone is the important
thing.
The veins are just a symptom.
Your whole body is experiencing an imbalance, so your health will benefit if you have a
blood test, for example, and get your progesterone at least, depending on your age, but it should
be a few times at least greater than the estrogen level.
Here's an interesting question.
This is from George.
He is in, I don't know where he is.
"When I have something with butter and a little maple syrup in the middle of the night,
it really helps me to go back to sleep sometime for four or five hours.
It could just be telling me about my body."
That's a good question.
What could that be saying that George's body is needing more of if he has butter and maple
syrup?
The maple syrup comes with some very good minerals, a lot of potassium that helps the
sugar work, and the sugar is kept in your stomach and intestine longer when there's
butter with it.
That's great.
Here's one for you.
"Are tamarinds and persimmons good and safe to eat?"
Yes.
Good.
Here's one for you.
What are some natural foods and supplements that Dr. Pete has seen to be successful in
restoring a full head of hair to a person experiencing what appears to be male pattern
baldness?
Okay.
Have you come up with some things over the years that guys have used to get back their
old hair?
It requires changing your whole course of health problems.
The hair loss tends to coincide with circulatory problems, and behind the circulatory problems
are metabolic problems.
So the things to work on are getting your vitamin D up, your thyroid and progesterone
and DHEA up, and your cortisol and the other stress hormones.
Aldosterone and parathyroid hormone are very destructive to the hair follicle and blood
vessels and heart.
And so if you change your metabolism, lowering parathyroid hormone and aldosterone and cortisol
and all of the stress-related hormones, including prolactin, that's going to save your circulatory
system as well as your hair.
So along with everything else, when we react to things in the world and angst and stress
and worry, you can lose hair over that.
Yeah, and at the same time, your whole health is suffering.
Do we know the physiological phenomena going on with the gray and why some people gray
early?
Is there any science behind that?
Do we know?
Yeah, I've thought about it and experimented with it quite a lot.
I started getting individual white eyebrows when I was in my 40s, and I was thinking about
the melanin in the brain being deficient in Parkinson's disease.
And thinking about what happens in that process, I realized that an excess of iron competes
against copper, and copper is the enzyme that makes the dark pigment.
And too much iron will simply get in the way and knock the copper out of your pigment enzymes.
And I didn't want to try just eating copper.
I made a solution.
Put a penny, a real copper penny.
In a little bottle of water with an aspirin tablet and about half a spoonful of vinegar.
So it had two acidic things to help the solvent.
So it was copper aspirinate and copper acetate that I was using in the solution.
And I put a drop of that on the white hair and watched it closely.
They grow very, very fast.
The very next day, and very visibly on the second day, I could see black pigment appearing
at the root.
Just essentially an instantaneous restoration of pigment formation.
Oh, that's pretty cool.
So you, go ahead, go ahead.
I did that on several hairs at different stages of their growth.
I would find one that was just starting out with a white tip and apply the copper and
the rest of it would, with just one application, the remaining hair would come out pigmented.
Did you ever do a lot of it and do it on top of your head?
Did you have any?
After that I started getting white whiskers on my cheeks and chin.
And I thought it would be a good test to put it under my lip on a little tuft of white
whiskers.
And by that time, the penny had been sitting in the solution for months and was very blue.
And I had a burning sensation and went to wash it off quickly and it kept burning.
So I kept dabbing it with water and finally looked to see what had happened that caused
that persistent stinging.
And rather than just finding a red area, I found a brown mole-like elevation all around
those white whiskers.
It had produced an instant mole, in effect, elevated pigmented cells.
Wow, you did a lot of pigmentation.
Yeah.
And changed the structure of the cells that invaded the area.
And so I just watched it and over a period of a month that had leveled out and disappeared.
But that got me interested in the phenomenon of pigment cell migration in the skin.
And the cells, it turns out that pigment cells can swim through the seemingly solid structure
of your skin.
They can travel almost an inch a day in warm weather when your skin temperature is around
90 degrees.
They can migrate with amazing speed.
And I found that if I provided them with the nutrients that they needed, which included
copper, that a mole would disperse or move and fade out, go back to being a normal pigmented
skin.
Interesting.
So you did the copper, aspirin, and vinegar, right?
Copper penny?
Yeah.
I found that on my sideburns, only about 10% of the white hairs reverted to black pigment
formation after one application.
And I realized that's because our eyebrows have a lifespan of only about a month.
Your facial hairs and head hairs live years.
Any one application is only going to affect a small percentage that are in the right phase
of growth.
I wonder if there'd be a source of copper you could experiment with other than trying
to find a pre-64 penny.
Yeah.
I decided the safest was just to eat more oysters.
Oysters?
Yeah, as a very strong source of copper.
Ah.
And safe.
Interesting.
Yeah.
In Ayurvedic medicine, they recommend folks put their water in a copper vessel in the
fridge and drink some of that every day.
Yeah, that's safe.
That's pretty safe?
Yeah.
That's really fun.
Interesting.
Here is Cody in Vero Beach, Florida.
I have a question about vaccines.
Dr. Pete had discussed how some vaccines and adjuvants more or less permanently alter our
body being as they, that so many people, even those born as early as 1950s, have been subjected
to vaccines and harmful adjuvants since a young age.
Are those that had vaccines hopeless in ever having true health?
Is the damage of the vaccine significant enough that no amount of good diet, healthy life,
and metabolic energy can reverse it?
If you look at the inflammatory and degenerative disease trend in young people, starting with
a great expansion of vaccination in America in the late 1980s, the increase of allergies
in young people and all of the inflammatory degenerative diseases, there's a steady sharp
increase starting around that year when the vaccine expansion happens.
So it's hard to explain this deterioration of health otherwise.
And it just makes it more urgent that these people start doing as many things right and
to basically start being skeptical about recommendations of the medical system.
Here's some good questions for you that have not been asked before.
We like new things.
It's always good.
Matthias, he says, "Does Dr. believe in the zeitgeist that proclaims homosexuals are born
that way?"
Well, there are enough studies in animals as well as people during a stress situation
such as famines, pregnancy subjected to extreme stress will cause great changes in their sexual
behavior including the sexual preference.
So it could be something that an idea and a feeling and a tendency that could happen
from birth that...
Everything that happens to you during gestation is shaping you, your whole system of mental
functions, emotions, physical shape, rate of metabolism, all of that.
This just in, this would be a timely thing, go ahead and mentioned it.
Supreme Court out with a decision today, landmark, which now features two new justices appointed
by President Trump.
Gay, lesbian, bisexual, trans individuals cannot legally be discriminated against by
employees meaning they can't be fired nor hired simply by being LGBTQ.
Just out this morning.
So that ties in with that.
And how does Dr. feel about abortions?
Wow, they're really going after you this morning, abortions.
Feel about what?
Abortions.
What's your...
It's best to control your conception but sometimes there's just not a system for properly
sustaining the pregnancy in a healthy way so it's never a good thing in any sense but
avoiding worse things I think it's a proper thing.
Do you have any theories or thought about when soul comes into the body?
Oh, I think it's there before the body actually.
There's continuity of soul.
In everything, right?
Yeah.
Here's another interesting one.
When you're looking back on your life and reflecting what's the advice you would give
someone maybe 50 years younger than you?
So Dr. Pete you've had your body what 83 years, right?
83?
Is that right?
So here's someone saying okay I'm 33 what advice can you give me?
Oh, stay alert is the main thing.
Times are going to get worse.
Just stay aware of what's going on in the world.
Yeah.
A couple more then we'll let you go.
Good questions this morning.
Thanks.
What does Dr. Pete think about a water filter through a Berkey water filter?
I know it's not reverse osmosis but a lot of credible people seem to like it.
Does it remove fluoride and other things?
I don't know what that kind is.
Reverse osmosis is good.
I don't know about Berkey either but pretty much is it.
Dr. Daniels has mentioned on Patrick's show that sauerkraut is used for internal scoring.
Do you know about this and can suggest it or add something else?
Internal scoring.
What kind of juice?
Sauerkraut.
Sauerkraut juice.
Oh.
I don't know.
It tastes nice.
If a person finds it pleasing, the salt can be a protective, relaxing factor that I don't
think has any harmful effects.
This is from JD.
Can Dr. Pete give me ideas on getting rid of ulcers?
What would you do to help somebody get rid of ulcers?
I suspect, I don't know, they're talking about stomach ulcers.
Is there a connection between some kind of a bacteria, what's it called?
Yeah, the pylori.
Pylori.
Yeah.
What do you know about stomach ulcers?
The stress predisposes the stomach to poor immunity.
Properly working digestive system is sterile and that depends on a complete good nutrition
with good thyroid function and getting a vigorous digestive process, lots of stomach, quick
production of digestive fluids, quick peristalsis, all of that will keep your upper digestive
tract completely sterile.
Do you think the meme that's out there that as we age we lose stomach acid, do you think
there's anything to that?
Yeah.
The stress hormones increase and the energy hormones decrease with age.
Thyroid becomes less effective because of anti-thyroid factors, inflammatory mediators,
the things that promote fibrosis and scarring and atrophy and inflammation all tend to increase
with aging and so all of the energizing anti-inflammatory things offset the aging process.
So could that be a tie in with people who are not busy and whatever, family disconnect
and on medicine and nursing homes that that all just piles on of one another?
Yeah and the things that have become so obvious with the COVID treatment and the facts of
natural immunity to the COVID are revealing new things about how to offset aging because
the things that cause the atrophy of aging predispose to the serious symptoms from the
virus and so for example, the low sartan or the entrotansin receptor blockers that have
been so effective against the symptoms of COVID also offset many of the problems of
aging, nerve degeneration, Alzheimer's type things, muscle frailty, osteoporosis, everything.
There's no distinction between the degeneration of aging and the degeneration that kills you
from a flu infection.
Dr. Ray Peat, final question and then we'll let you go.
So in all of your experience being on this planet 83 years and looking at this for 50
years or so, do you think it's at all possible that a safe and effective virus for this COVID-19,
whatever it is, could be available in the fall or even early next year?
A vaccine for it?
Yes sir, a vaccine.
No, has there ever been a safe and effective vaccine?
The whole issue of safety testing has been fraudulent.
The CDC disobeyed an order of Congress in not doing safety studies when they gave the
pharmaceutical industry immunity from damages caused by killing people with bad vaccines.
When they gave them that immunity, they were obligated by Congress to do safety testing
and report every two years.
For 30 years, they did absolutely nothing.
And the safety testing that has been done, for example, if you think that the aluminum
adjuvant has been causing deaths and brain damage, you would test it against a blank,
something for sure not containing aluminum, but they used aluminum in the so-called placebo.
They used a toxic placebo to measure the toxicity of the vaccine.
Deliberate intentional fraud.
So Bobby Kennedy and his group did a FOIA request for safe and effective studies and
they just turned up empty.
So you're suggesting that even for measles, mumps, or rubella, there's never been safe
and effective testing done on these guys.
And the same with flu vaccines.
Flu vaccines, never.
And I think it's important to look at who the U.S. Public Health Service and the CDC
is, who they are, and who the organization has been, what they've been doing historically.
During my lifetime, there have been just horrible, incredible scandals that they managed to keep
secret.
They said if some good organization found out about this, there could be a lot of smoke.
For example, that they were infecting orphans in Guatemala with syphilis as part of a secret
experiment.
That they were covering up evidence of radiation damage from nuclear accidents in experimental
reactors in the United States and from Three Mile Island.
They've been on the side of the offenders, keeping the information from the public.
Dr. Ray Peet, PhD.
He's here on the third Monday of every month.
Dr. Peet, thanks so much for your time once a month.
We really appreciate it.
RayPeat.com.
And you can click on the link and then it'll take you right to RayPeatnewsletter@gmail.com
if you'd like to sign up.
And they just send you an email and then you work it out with the folks, right?
Who send you an email?
RayPeatnewsletter@gmail.com.
Well, Dr. Peet, happy painting.
And we'll talk to you next month.
Let us know if there's ever anything we can do for you, if we can help you get any additional
information out.
We're always available.
We'd have you on any time.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you, sir.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
Dr. Ray Peet, RayPeatnewsletter.com.
What a wonderful find to have this gentleman available.
Thanks for all your great questions.
Boy, you had some good ones today, baby.
Yeah, we always do.
Okay, we have Dr. Christine Northrup, who's quite an interesting lady.
Sharon has put up a nice video of her on the front page of One Radio Network.
So come by tomorrow, we're going to talk to her.
And then we're going to dig into the world of finance and geopolitics with Paul Reiter.
He says that five times in the last 90 years, five times in the last 90 years, let me see
if I can read the whole thing, elements of US power structure have tried to oust a sitting
president without an election.
Five times.
Can you guess who those were?
Can you guess?
Five times.
And then Brandon Smith.
He's quite a fascinating fellow.
I think his website is altmarkets.com.
Yeah, Brandon Smith, he'll be here on Wednesday.
So cool stuff coming up.
I love you all very much.
Thanks for your ongoing support.
Been an honor to be here with you.
We're getting closer, I think, to having the video thing tracking every day.
So you can see the guest and we're making some headway with that.
So again, if I can do anything for you during the week after the show, Patrick@OneRadioNetwork.com.
I love you all very much.
Thank you and may the blessings be.
We talk about your health, wealth and well-being on OneRadioNetwork.com.
[MUSIC]
[BLANK_AUDIO]